Ethan boy what a dude how is it
how's it going man bro I'm good I'm good
I'm ready bro Habibi this is this is the
moment you've been waiting for you made
it this far smash the like button spam
the comments with shahada time uh and
Ethan bro before we go right into it I
want to know a little bit about your
journey thus far right so of course
we're going to do the shahada but please
let us know bro anything and everything
you want to share about what made you
get to this point right now
yeah
um basically I was raised as an atheist
um in fact I'd actually see my family
I'm more antitheists the kind of like
mocked religion my whole life
um but myself I was always more agnostic
but
I suppose the last
six months or so I started watching like
debates between Muslims Christians
atheists Jews every single time the
Muslim would win I'd never saw a Muslim
lose at any debate ever
um so I suppose
that's that's what led me here
personally
I mean
I I dealt with addiction for many years
um and the only thing that helped me
come out with that was my relationship
with God
I'm at a point in my life now where
I need to take it to the next step I
think
Angela okay cool bro so we're just gonna
go over a little bit about some of the
beliefs that you required to be a Muslim
yes um so these we have the five floors
of Islam these are basically the five
things that are required from you as a
Muslim
and then there's the six pillars of his
Iman right the six pillars of Iman or
Iman Loosely translated to Faith right
but there's there's so many other ways
to describe it but just convict the lack
of what it would
um these are things that are basically
requisite for you to be Muslim so
they're not really responsibilities or
things you have to do like the five
pillars of Islam but these are more so
things that we need to just see where
your approach it's very simple questions
um if you don't mind so we'll go over
those all right any questions yeah sure
and I'll go ahead go ahead
so the first question is do you believe
in Allah that there's there's a Creator
there's God and God is one 100 100
perfect do you believe in the Angels the
angels that Allah sends to give
Revelation I do yes and then the third
thing is the Revelation that I just
mentioned the Revelation
um or scripture you know the Quran and
the previous scriptures that God has
sent
yes perfect do you believe them I've got
to go on here bro that's perfect and do
you believe in the messages Messengers
or prophets of God that Allah sends
Revelation to to then relay to mankind
absolutely perfect do you believe in the
day of judgment that one day we're going
to be held into account for all of our
Good Deeds
um and everything like that yes perfect
do you believe in Divine decree or
predestination which we call the color
of Allah so that Allah is all-knowing
and basically has a Divine decree laid
out for us yes perfect bro that's it I
think I think you're qualified and I
think you you have that understanding
alhamdulillah now with regards to the
five pillars of Islam is basically going
to be you know the shahada which is
necessary for you to become a Muslim
um that's the first thing the second one
is prayer yeah your five daily prayers
we'll talk about all that bro we'll
create like a group chat with me you
angel and Rami uh we'll send you some
resources too and it's a step-by-step
thing but the child is the most
important
um the third and fourth are you know
fasting in the month of Ramadan if
you're able to uh no medical conditions
or anything like that and then the zakat
which is the 2.5 percent
of our unused excessive wealth that just
sits in your possession that we have to
give to the needy and then the fifth one
is Hajj which is the pilgrimage uh that
we make to the Kaaba in Saudi Arabia at
least once in your life if you are able
to does that make sense yeah yeah so
that's it how are you feeling great
okay sounds good bro so let me pull this
up right now in Arabi and then I will
basically read out and you can just
repeat after me sound good yep
[Music]
I bear witness I bear witness that there
is none that there is none worthy of
worship worthy of worship except Allah
except Allah and I bear witness and I
bear witness the prophet Muhammad the
prophet Muhammad is the final messenger
and servant of God is the final
messenger and servant of God
you're not Muslim thank you I appreciate
that guys
of course bro
I feel like a weight's been lifted off
my shoulders I've been waiting a while
to do this to be honest really yeah
oh man oh no bro
bro
it's just a real experienced man you're
probably gonna feel that for like a good
month yeah
more than that definitely
um bro do you have any questions or
anything like that because I'm sure you
know now that you became Muslim
obviously alhamdulillah we have this
little bit of a spiritual High which is
fine um but I'm sure if you have any
questions bro we'd love to you know go
through some of these things
yeah I guess
um what's the next step from here okay
so the next step that I recommend is
going to be to learn how to pray no
prayer or Salah Loosely is as again we
know it's Loosely translated to prayer
um but worship would be a better term
because understanding that the main Neo
or intention of us doing SLA is yeah we
can make Dua which is asking Allah and
no one said you can't do it but it
should be irrespectable we should be we
should be prostrating and worshiping
Allah by virtue of Allah not necessarily
because of what we want to get out of it
although we will get tremendous benefits
out of it for sure
um and these prayers we have five
minimum obligatory prayers per day
there's optional ones like Doha and then
which is a night prayer but don't need
to think about that right now the five
daily prayers are the basics no
in Islam right understand that
because you're a revert you have a clean
slate all of your sins are forgiven
inshallah and now we need to start from
the basics so first I would say learning
how to pray is going to be important so
we can send you some videos that we send
the reverts to basically go over how to
pray what the movements are so you get
comfortable with that right then you
know you can do it step by step guided I
just recommend memorizing Surah Fatiha
which is the first chapter of the Quran
it's not that difficult to memorize at
all
um if you recite it even it's it's like
30 30 seconds bro it's not like a long
thing or anything
um so you could play that on repeat for
like a day or two I've I've known people
that memorized it that quick it's not
anything difficult understand the
meaning too and then basically I would
recommend you to just start praying one
prayer a day right I'm not going to tell
you go into it start five out of five
burn out it's better that you slowly
build this up and not burn out then try
to be on ten toes down right away a few
months and then burn burn out you know
what I mean yeah yeah start with one a
day
um there's different times of them you
can download a Prayer app just with
prayer times or Salat times the first
prayer is fudger right so this is going
to be
um around Don so don is give or take an
hour or two before Sunrise depending on
where you are
um and that's the hours that it's valid
so basically you cannot pray Fajr until
Fajr time comes which is done
um and then it's it's basically you're
done the the time to make that Prayer by
Sunrise so it doesn't mean you can't
make it up after Sunrise if you have a
valid excuse or you forgot or you know
you just overslept you you had the
intention of getting up that's fine
um but we should pray on time and we can
talk about that in uh DMS then you have
tohar and Asar which are like during the
day you have Maghrib which is right at
Sunset so Maghrib as long as you know
when Sunset is that's as long as it's
valid and then Isha when it comes to the
prayers too Allah has given this for us
bro so I know a lot of people are like
oh why why are muslims praying all the
time you know like why do you guys need
to do this why does your God need this
God doesn't need this bro we need Salah
you know what I mean yeah and Allah has
so much Mercy on us that he didn't even
make Salah obligatory
um the normal way for people that are
traveling or are ill and stuff like that
so for example if you're traveling
um I believe Scholars can have a
consensus that the distance is about 80
kilometers or so so pretty much leaving
your house going more than 80 kilometers
um if you're traveling overseas you are
basically in the state of being a
traveler so in that state you don't even
have to pray all of the prayers into
entirety so some of them have basically
four Cycles they change to two cycles
they're shortened you can also combine
them literally it's a mercy but it's
made very easy on us and you're a new
revert so I don't expect you to you know
get to that point that you want to get
overnight it's not realistic it's not
feasible but it's very important that we
start with the first steps
um so inshallah we'll we'll touch base
with you in Instagram and just cover a
little bit about how to pray
yeah I really appreciate that okay of
course bro what's next
um well I suppose I mean I have already
been praying I usually pray as soon as I
wake up and before I go to bed I don't
really know how to pray though you know
it's kind of
I don't know I don't know I would
describe that I do it but I don't know
how to do it properly would it be in
Arabic would I have to pray in Arabic oh
would it be okay in English
yeah so the the prayers are in Arabic
and this is something that you have to
learn but again it's like why you said
you don't have to rush you know there is
no rush here Allah knows what's in your
heart and as long as you're making the
intention and making the action not just
the intention but the action and you're
doing little by little little by little
to get to that point
Allah is rewarding you and accepting it
from you the same way
you know it's like it's it doesn't make
sense for you to rush and then burn out
and then not pray at all you know of
course yeah yeah and
um
I just wanted to say my experience
um I I reiterize it because I already
said it earlier in this video
um but for myself man I would literally
put my phone up like this
and I would put a video of this guy
praying
and I'll just follow along bro I had no
idea what to do or what to say but after
doing that several times I started
getting the feel for like the Motions
the movements and then I started
learning the actual Arabic and um
if I were to convince the time frame
because for me like I was all over the
place but if I were to condense the time
frame I think in less than a week I was
able to do the uh the tour I got just
basically the prayer the normal prayer
at least the Fajr and or no all the
prayers because it's all doing the Surah
Fatiha and then you can add this from
the prayers after
I just want to clarify one thing bro
um someone said wait isn't optional I
never said that is option I said Doha
d-u-h-a uh it's the one in between Fajr
and and that is
Lam
um yeah Ethan bro what else what else is
on your mind
well
um
I suppose since I've already started
prayer I can just implement the Islamic
prayer into the prayer I've already been
doing right that's that would be fine
yeah
but I have a feeling that the prayer
you're doing now is is a form of Dua
where you're like you're asking Allah
for something maybe it's for
um Peace maybe it's for understanding
maybe it's for guidance or something
like this am I correct yeah guidance
always
okay but continue continue
um I lost my train of thought
um no no worries bro I was just gonna
add to that too that in Islam
um the default for basically Halal and
Haram meaning like things that we should
abstain from and things that we are
permissible in partaking in
um these things as a generality in
principle
um or everything is halal or permissible
unless explicitly mentioned that it's
Haram so when it comes to most Affairs
in life you can do them unless obviously
there's Revelation or Hadith attending
Hadith or an eye on the Quran basically
making it clear that it's not
permissible you know what I mean but
then when it comes to ibada or acts of
worship here it's the opposite so here
everything's impermissible unless it's
specifically mentioned to be permissible
so someone can't I heard this this one
guy being like Oh I play the musical
some musical instrument for God it's
like okay you know what I mean like sure
I'm sure they have the right intention
but it's not paired with the right
action so because in Islam we have to
adhere to exactly what God wants from us
in terms of the acts of worship
um I would just recommend to learn
um take your time you know and we're
here for you every step of the way
inshallah but take your time to learn
how to pray Salah and then in Salah
itself you can actually make these Dua
when you're prostrating with your head
on the on the floor you can actually
make these Duos that you're making
anyway when you pray you can ask for
protection guidance peace wealth
anything you want if you're going
through a struggle trials and
tribulations you can cry out to Allah
and I think it'll it'll be a little bit
more befitting as a Muslim what do you
think
you can make Dua at any point too yeah
yeah don't think that you you can only
make them during like the prayer times
like yeah it's separate to the prayer
right
you can combine it you can do it like
like fayetteson you know if you're
making the prostration after you say
what has to be said then you can make
Dua in that prostration
if you wake up at like 3 A.M in the
morning and you can make duas it's not
like you have to prepare yourself to
meet dwell now you can make the world
bro it's it's only after or before the
the main prayers and before the Sunnah
prayers as well that we perform we do
we'll do is the the cleansing
that we do before going into the prayers
the actual
um I'd say the the ritualistic prayers
right I understand I've got here yeah
yeah
um so my next question would be
obviously I'm someone who's sinned a lot
in my life
I'm sure I'll sin again
what how do we cope with that when you
do things that you know are wrong
um beautiful bro so
it's known through Islam that if
mankind did not sin right with the
children of Adam peace be upon him did
not sin then Allah would destroy us
literally destroy us bro and replace us
with a people or civilization that does
sin just so we can repent and understand
the value of Allah's Mercy what does
this mean it basically means that Allah
understands that every son and I believe
the prophet saws mentioned this in
Hadith too that every son of Adam is a
sinner like every like there's no
exception bro
um the best of Sinners are those that
repent you know what I mean so
understanding that sinning by nature is
nothing weird or bad or something you
should be nihilistic about understanding
obviously ignorance and arrogance are
two different things so if you're
ignorant and you don't know it's a
lifelong journey bro the thing with
Islam is
it's it's very multifaceted you're not
going to understand everything that our
sins and things we should avoid
overnight bro I'm like a couple years
into practicing Islam myself and I'm
just like I still have moments where I
am finding out new things you know what
I mean I'm sure that's the same with
Arnold too so it's it's a lifelong thing
treated as that
um but understand you're gonna sin when
you do sin the best thing that you could
do is repent uh sincerely to Allah and
actually make Dua to Allah to help you
overcome these things you know I know
today we're a little bit too Dunya or
materialistic related in our Affairs we
think that okay if I have a medical
condition then I need a medication if I
have this mental problem I need therapy
if I'm financially struggling I just
need to go out and make more money so I
get it bro it's the input output X and Y
but when it comes to our Affairs as
Muslims we should always rely on Allah
first and foremost the is something huge
because many people don't right so I
know you might be like okay if you're
struggling with let's say nofap or
you're struggling with some addiction
right I know you might want to go watch
YouTube videos and other advice and I'm
sure there's practical advice I'm not
denying that but relying first and
foremost on Allah is pivotal bro to make
it easy for you making Allah I'm
struggling with this I want to leave
this for your sake please help me
overcome this please help me abstain
from this and you'll immensely notice
this like spiritual boost and you're
just being basically protected by Allah
from these things yeah I've already
experienced that to be honest you have
right but like I said and I dealt with
addiction from like the ages of
12 till last year when I'm 22 now so you
know that's like drugs and [__]
um sorry my language but
yeah it was obviously a very a very
difficult thing to deal with addiction
and the only thing that ever did help
was prayer so yeah that makes sense
that's amazing bro I know what do you
say about sins
well look the beautiful thing is that
when you become Muslim all your sins are
wiped away alhamdulillah
but that's not to say that we're going
to be seeing this you know like
and
just know that the I'd say the first
multiple times that you've seen
after this point from you or not and
again like I don't I don't want you to
sing I'm not trying to like
uh
foreshadow or something like bad things
happening to you no I'm not a strong
moon but all I'm saying is that they
never agree like as humans we are going
to sin and I'm telling you about like as
a river when you do sin after you've
like been wiped away from all your sins
oh it hurts man
it hurts and like you you'll be in
prayer you'll be in like prostration
and you'll just be crying because it's
like it's just like it it's real man
it's not fake at all it's real
and all I can say is that uh this is
Hadith where the Prophet Muhammad is
he he said that
when one sins
uh it's like this black dot goes on your
heart
and the more you sin the more these
black dots begin to increase until your
heart is covered in this Veil this like
Black Veil and at that point once it
gets to that point you no longer know
what's good from what's bad
at that point you'll do something that's
bad and you'll think it's good for you
or you'll do something that's good for
you and you think it's bad and then you
don't want to do it at all so when it
comes to that point it's like
well actually you don't want to you
don't actually let it come to that point
you know you always want to be making
repentance and asking for forgiveness to
Allah but just know that
um if you ever do start getting to this
point like Allah is the most merciful
Allah is the one that's like it's
literally it's his two of his names
it's like the most merciful and the most
the especially merciful
and there's another one there especially
most for any especially
um
I know that means the most merciful
means especially merciful uh I see yeah
see yeah
is it I believe so let me let me Google
that while you look it up I don't think
that's what it is I got you bro
means the most beneficent
um or the most merciful and then
means
yeah especially merciful or continuous
merciful yes but but look how beautiful
that is bro that like
I'll bro Allah knows what's you know
Allah knows that we're gonna sin Allah
knows everything because he's already
written it bro he's not really written
it and it's not because he intends bad
for us when we do these things but it's
because he intends the best for us he
wants us to learn he wants us to grow
and we as humans we don't grow unless we
suffer unless we struggle through
adversity
so we have to go through these things
and Allah always all of that all Allah
asks us to do or it tells us to do it
should not asked he tells us just come
back to him trust in him that's it you
don't have to do anything like if you're
over here crying and you're suffering
because you're addicted to something or
or you're having these issues like bro
like go to Allah Allah is the one that's
gonna heal you Allah is the one that's
going to take care of everything for you
you don't have money bro Allah is the
one that's going to provide for you you
don't have food to you Allah is the one
that's going to provide for you
you're sick Bro the doctor could give
you a medicine but if if Allah doesn't
will for this medicine to cure you the
medicine's not going to do anything so
again it's it's all goes back to Allah
so as long as you keep going back to
Allah no matter what you do
you know what can you do like just keep
asking for forgiveness keep going back
to Allah and
remember that Allah is the most merciful
the especially move I love that bro may
Allah bless you for that and Ethan bro I
hope that that kind of resonated a
little bit hit something in your heart
um because it definitely resonated with
me
um so someone writes or asks what
happens if your heart is completely
blocked like Donald said um if you
didn't make it clear already like Allah
does basically make it very known in the
Quran which is the second chapter of the
Quran that basically those that have
healed hearts or their hearts are sealed
at that point like that's it bro there's
not much you could do but but Allah also
mentions in the same Surah in Surah
al-baqarah that never will anyone be
misguided or basically not get the
guidance from Allah unless those that
are defiantly disobedient and arrogant
meaning the people that they just don't
even want to be safe bro they don't even
want to open their window to the truth
so if you generally want to pray for
guidance like brother Ethan has been
doing you will inshallah get get hit on
we gotta we gotta trust in that yeah and
then sister can you please talk about
Free Will and Destiny I'm so confused so
in Islam there's one disclaimer that I
want to give very clearly to everyone
listening and tuning in that there's
many things that are areas of confusion
or doubt sometimes we are unclear on
these things right and I want to make a
known that the answers to all these
questions are are all out there they've
all been answered you can find them
online it's very simple so anytime you
do come across something where it's like
a doubt or you're like oh how does this
make sense or how do I basically
rationalize this understand you can come
to us DM us at the three Muslims on IG
or do some research online now
pertaining to this
I'm sure a lot of you maybe brother
Ethan maybe brother Angel I know at
least myself I came across this doubt um
or confusion when I was you know very
new into practicing Islam that what is
this whole thing about Free Will and
Destiny because if if God gave us free
will right and we we are in control of
if we sin or not sin but then God also
broke down what we're gonna do how are
we accountable then didn't God make us
do these things and no because God
didn't make us do these things see the
Divine decree or the color of Allah that
was basically written in everything that
everyone's going to do every decision
someone's gonna make right
they weren't things that Allah made us
do Allah just wrote down before we were
even here what we're gonna do
so in a sense it's basically writing
down what the decree is what everyone's
going to do all the sins they're going
to commit it's not that Allah made like
a program or anything and then clicked
execute and then we just did all these
things no we still have free will Allah
wrote down everything that we did with
our own free will
Allah also wrote down everything and in
the other things that we didn't do and
what would have happened had we done
those things but we didn't so the Divine
decree is very multifaceted but it's not
something that God made us do so I want
everyone to understand that it's just
it's basically writing down everything
that we will do
um but we still did it in the sense so
we can't blame like oh God wrote this so
I'm gonna do it no God wrote it but you
still did it if that makes sense
you know you know the whole Free Will
and Destiny team that's something I
never was really confused about hunting
there just because I've always played
video games when I was younger
the example that I want to give is like
you have a video game which is created
by a developer
right this video game has many many
different ways that the the game can end
but the Creator the developer of this
video game knows exactly all the ways
that it can help
right
now when you as the gamer plays this
game
you have the free will to choose
whatever you want in this game and what
you choose will depict what the end of
the game is going to be what the outcome
of the game is going to be how the
experience is going to be but the one
who created the video game already knows
exactly what it is that you're going to
experience
yeah and then when this happened it's
like
that's it's a lot like life man like
Allah has created everything Allah has
already written it all and we are here
just making decisions if you if you
really think about your life
all it is is just the decisions that you
make because the decisions you make
results in an action and the action
results in a reaction but it's all
decisions bro this entire life is all
decisions and these decisions is what
free will is and the Free Will is what
begins to unravel what your life is
right now and what it's going to be and
how it's going to end and where you're
going to end up at the end
um I do want to add to that beautiful
point that we're not comparing a lot to
video game developers it's just an
analogy and we must understand that
video game developers are made from
human beings that are limited and they
basically code them in a way where
there's there's kind of like an
algorithm or like an order of events
that could happen whereas the god of
Allah Allah still did the same thing but
Allah also wrote down what we actually
end up doing where the video game it's
kind of like open source like you could
go this way or that way Allah also gave
us the option but knows which one we
were going to do we still made that
decision once again to go this way or
that way so Allah didn't make us do it
in a way
um but just wanted to clear that up
100.
Ethan bro anything else and don't feel
like you have to create questions that
you don't even have uh just because I
keep asking you I just want to make sure
that you leave this with a little bit of
security and certainty
um in some of the things that might be a
little bit unclear if there are any
yeah so
I mean I don't really know many Muslims
in person the ones I I used to know were
I wouldn't say though they were they
were the best Muslims or like dealers
and and stuff
um
I suppose how do I go about
networking we've got two other Muslims
where are you from where do you live in
England a city called Hull in England
okay DM me that on IG I'm gonna put out
a community post on on T3 on Instagram
and I'll find some beautiful Brothers
for you to be connected to number one
inshallah number two you can go to the
Masjid and for the mosques and
just organically find the community but
I think doing it this way it'll take a
little bit of the pressure away
um and understand it's it's one of those
things like I want to give a huge shout
out to brother Anthony and West if you
are watching this bro uh he did a
shahada
um and then he got on the stream with us
I think months ago but even a year ago
and he is a rebirth as well from America
and right now he has an amazing
Community he's always posting stuff on
IG
um because I follow him and he's he's
posting you know going to these events
these Retreats and he has a huge
community of Muslims when he reverted he
didn't really know anyone so it's very
normal it's a kind of like it's like
if you ever go to college out of state
you know day one you don't know anyone
there you you're coming from high school
you're coming from your old Clique you
come into college you don't know anyone
here you don't know where anything is
it's all new right but then look at
someone in like fourth year or their
final year of college they're not going
to be lonely they're going to know
everyone so understand it's just
something that comes with time I think
on Health phone definitely died so
inshallah he can make it back before we
wrap it up but I just want to make it
make it clear that it's there's no
pressure and it's just something we just
got to take step by step but I will do
my best to facilitate that um when you
DM me the city see if there's anyone
there there's going to be a lot of
people inshallah yeah okay great yeah I
think that's all to be honest I'm the
love bro so if you have no other
questions I think inshallah we'll just
touch base in Instagram uh the group
chat that I make and in the meantime uh
just make some Dua to Allah to continue
keeping you steadfast in the right path
to keep your arms away and everyone in
the comments uh we're in the war chat
please make the welcome brother Ethan
um that he stays on the right path and
more and more people can be influenced
by him though so the prophet saws
um this is something unique to Islam you
know in other religions sure they were
given Messengers and Prophets right but
when you look at Islam the prophet peace
be upon him not only gave us Revelation
but in his final sermon and in many of
his thoughts he basically told us that
dawah or spreading Islam spreading the
truth is something we must take on a
personal level too it doesn't just end
with him his resolution peace be upon
him it's something that we should all do
so that's why right now
um understand that you know the prophet
saws mentioned convey from me even if
it's one verse literally one verse like
one line of the Quran so it just goes to
show that you won't have to become a
scholar number one you don't need to go
to Street Dao or none of this bro but
first and foremost you're a clock
leading by example and being in good
character that's first and foremost bro
and and this could be something like for
example let's say some of us have foul
speech or we grew up in the west people
are swearing cussing rap music whatever
right all of a sudden you become Muslim
and let's say you understand Allah
doesn't really like foul speech it's not
befitting we represent Islam let's say
you make these changes and you stop
swearing right this alone is that well
you're not telling anyone about the
Quran you're not telling anyone about
anything but they know you're Muslim now
you're a little bit more empathetic you
know what I mean so that what doesn't
necessarily have to be active direct
dawa
um talking about Islam preach teaching
it could also be indirect and that's
like the first and foremost the bare
minimum
um but I just wanted to leave you with
that because I understand that
um now people will use you as an example
and a lot of people that might be on the
fence maybe even someone brother living
in England now maybe close to you
watching this video they're like oh I've
been Christian I've been thinking of
Islam I don't know what to do oh brother
Ethan did it and that inspired him maybe
let's see to take the shout out tonight
in his bedroom so you gotta understand
that now we are a force of good and we
have to continue making Allah to keep us
that force of good and allow us to
inspire more people and inshaallah will
accept it from us
I think with that being said bro
um inshallah we will touch base and to
everyone watching in stay tuned for uh
this Wednesday we will stream and then
Saturday and a week from now we're gonna
bring on Sunny fast and his mom for part
two inshallah smash the like button down
below and with that being said salaam
alaikum